There's a
monitor lizard right there,
right on that termite mound,
just basking in the sun.
They can either play
dead or they can run
like grease lightning.
Let me see if I can
get a better look at it.
I can see that this
monitor could use a little help.
It's actually kind of
good that I found you because
I'll be real gentle.
Oh, yeah, you're
grabbing a hold.
You are starting to wake up.
But here's what I want to do.
See all these.
Look at these horrible ticks.
They get these parasites on them
and they just suck their blood.
Let's make your day so
much better by getting rid of
some of these nasty parasites.
Nobody likes ticks,
including myself.
Monitors have powerful jaws
that can crush bones and even
through hard shells of turtles.
And have special
toxins in their saliva that
stops blood from coagulating.
This is just a baby.
They can get pretty easily,
six feet long.
So, they're the
biggest lizard in Africa and
they can defend
themselves with those big,
sharp claws with a
very powerful bite.
You can see those big
claws built for climbing trees,
built for climbing termite
mounds and built for grabbing
a hold of the ground
when it's in a dead sprint.
They have a forked tongue
that's a lot like a snake, uh.
They can sort of
smell or sense the air.
Well, this was a really,
really lucky find.
But I'm just going to let
you go right where I found you.
(grunts)
Pretty smart lizard.
Cool.